okay so check this out
when we first heard
about this
absolutely horrible story of a
ten-year-old girl
raped and impregnated in ohio unable to
get an abortion in ohio because of the
law having to go to indiana the right
wingers
started doing two things one is they
said it's fake it's a fake story it's
made up none of it is true none of this
is happening no one's going to indiana
absolutely not
and the second part of it was saying
is it a crime to go to indiana for an
abortion we've got to find the doctor
sending the girl to indiana we've got to
find the doctor performing the abortion
in indiana we need to charge these
people which is a crazy reaction but
let's focus on the first part which was
it's made up none of it is true well it
turns out that it is true and suddenly
because the suspected rapist is believed
to be an undocumented immigrant they've
quietly these right-wingers who first
said it was a fake story they've started
saying well yeah
she had to go to indiana for an abortion
thanks to that no good illegal that joe
biden led let into the country now first
of all
i've seen no evidence that this
individual entered the country during
the biden administration maybe true may
not be completely irrelevant to the
story but check out some of these
examples governor christie gnome
uh tweeted a week ago dana bash tried to
trap me with a story about a 10 year old
girl who got an abortion i pointed out
nobody was asking about the pervert who
raped that child now it looks like the
story was fake to begin with
literal fake news
from the liberal media well it turns out
that that story is absolutely and
completely true and christinome uh just
called it fake for no reason there was
no reason to believe it was fake there's
a guy named clay travis okay he has a
radio show and he's on
um
some fox show he writes books and you
know this type of thing okay he tweeted
multiple times that the story is
straight straight up fake check these
out everything joe biden said here
appears to be a lie ohio law ohio a law
allows abortion for raped children and
more importantly there is zero evidence
that this actually happened tweeting
again media reports of a 10 year old
girl being raped in ohio and having to
leave the state for an abortion appear
to be completely made up tweeting again
clay travis rips apart indie star and
the rest of the leftist media
for allowing the story about a 10 year
old seeking an abortion to go viral well
the story was completely true
and now with absolutely no
egg on his face no embarrassment
whatsoever which he should be feeling
clay travis updates the story and says
updating this viral story which you said
shouldn't have gone viral a 27 year old
illegal immigrant in ohio has been
arrested for raping a ten-year-old girl
the girl could have gotten an abortion
in ohio under state law but traveled to
indiana to have the abortion instead so
now the focus is well that's an
undocumented immigrant
ohio congressman jim jordan who by the
way does not exactly have a track record
of reporting and taking seriously
believed in alleged
uh assault of minors but that's a story
for a different day he deleted uh his
tweet he posted another lie anyone
surprised about the story
and then that tweet has mysteriously
disappeared sorry
that tweet has been deleted
they don't apologize they instill fear
and say it's the left-wing media that's
lying to you they can't be trusted they
can't be believed the entire thing is
made up then it turns out they were
lying and then they just move on to the
next thing now here they have a little
bit of an escape shoot because the
perpetrator the alleged perpetrator is
believed to be an undocumented immigrant
if it weren't for that they would just
be they wouldn't even talk about the
story they now have a new angle a new
straw to grasp onto which is this is an
undocumented immigrant and it's joe
biden's fault and look at the terrible
thing that an undocumented immigrant did
well you were just saying that it never
happened and now the problem is a
different one
completely predictable and again
they will very casually say
the story is fake
even when there is no reason to believe
that the story is fake it was very real
it's a tragedy it's a result in part of
the abortion laws that these very same
people want to be the laws in these
states that's where we are
and they just don't it's the trumpian
approach you can apologize you just move
on you pretend you were never wrong or
you move on to something else some shiny
new object they do it every time and
they're not going to stop we'll have
more on these stories on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
later on we're going to look at some
incredible video
of a republican congressman
talking about post-birth abortion which
isn't a thing i mean it quite literally
doesn't exist we'll get to that later on
in the show
one of our sponsors is better help the
customized online therapy service that
offers video phone and live chat with
your therapist you don't even have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to you fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your specific needs and then
you're matched with a licensed therapist
in under 48 hours you can schedule
secure video and phone sessions you can
exchange unlimited messages with your
therapist and you can request a new
therapist at any time for any reason at
no charge talking to a therapist doesn't
mean there's something wrong with you it
means you're doing something for
yourself and for your wellness you get
your car serviced you work out you see
the doctor to prevent physical illness
and disease
therapy is the same thing anyone can
benefit from it i think it's very
important join the 2 million plus people
who have taken charge of their mental
health with better help get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com pacman the
link is down below